at first my thoughts on America and
shutdown day 50/50 hard to believe after
China's lies and deceit about the
coronavirus the American public I think
it's finally beginning to get it they're
seeing the communist nation for what it
is an enemy of the United States and a
free people everywhere a Pew Research
poll last month showed that two-thirds
of Americans now have an unfavorable
view of China an RNC survey showed
similarly negative views on China among
voters in several key battleground
states now long before this first case
of covered 19 showed up in Seattle China
had co-opted the World Health
Organization we've talked a lot about
that recently just as they've done by
the way with Wall Street our top
universities and the American media
Hollywood well their MO is always the
same dangled promises of huge financial
support or profits as long as everyone
looks the other way on their horrendous
human rights and economic record by
using this approach over the last two
decades or so now China has grown in
wealth they've grown in power and
they've grown in prestige across every
sector they made the cynical calculation
that high-powered Westerners would take
short-term payoffs in exchange for
freedom and independence that sacrifice
the latter well they were right sadly at
least until they met their match in
Donald Trump his America first
approached to trade put China on the
defensive and it forced China to the
negotiating table making concessions and
eventually a trade deal a trade deal
that Obama and Bush could or would never
make the globalists were happy with our
relationship with China during those 16
years president Trump though right now
is trying to walk a fine line he's not
as harsh as China as I'd be but he has a
different job he is trying to balance
our economic needs that are very big
right now
with national security and let me be
clear no one and I mean no one has done
more to stand up to China and tackle the
challenges that they pose than Donald J
Trump his administration is filled with
hardcore China realists China is a very
serious threat to the United States
geopolitically economically militarily
and a threat to the integrity of our
institutions its assess our
vulnerabilities and it's decided to
exploit our freedoms to gain advantage
over us our message to China's rulers is
this this president will not back down
the American people will not be swayed
but the problem is too many elites are
still totally in the tank for China the
worst offenders when you think of all
the really bad offenders out there the
worst are perhaps the universities and
their connections with China and thus
the CCP run deep
since 2013 China has given a billion
dollars to 115 colleges and universities
Harvard was the biggest recipient
pulling in ninety three point seven
million but that's not all a huge number
of Chinese students handpicked by the
CCP are admitted at universities cluding
Harvard including by the way President
Xi's daughter who graduated from Harvard
just a few years back now Harvard has
even set up an academic center in
Shanghai and established a Harvard China
fund which supports teaching and
research on China and also promotes
Harvard's presence in China China has
given Harvard as I said ninety three
point seven million 2270 Chinese
students and scholars at Harvard Harvard
now has an academic center in China all
of this that we've just talked about
this is stunning stunning stuff and by
the way Harvard's recruitment of Chinese
scholars and Chinese Connexions my
favorite story a renowned Harvard
researcher Charles Lieber was bus
for allegedly lying about his
involvement in a Chinese recruitment
operation the PRC had paid him 50,000
bucks a month plus living expenses for
his work at Wuhan University of
Technology and get this he ran his own
nanoscience Center at Harvard he's a
brainiac he received 15 million dollars
in grants from wait for it the NIH all
the while he was taking big money from
China to allegedly help them recruit
talent to then steal our trade secrets
this was Harvard's president last March
Harvard is an American University as
Veda is a Chinese University our
institutions have a responsibility to
contribute positively to our own
societies and to the national good as
well as to the world at large but as
universities we fulfill this charge
precisely by embodying and defending
academic values that transcend the
boundaries of any one country
I love the soundtrack by the way
underneath that transcend the boundaries
of any nation well as we see in the
current pandemic boundaries do in fact
matter and the CCP's values aren't our
values but this isn't limited to Harvard
not trying to pick on Harvard he's
happened to be the biggest China has
plants among students and researchers
across America most recently at the
University of Texas UCLA and the
University of Kansas and again you the
US taxpayers are perversely funding this
now for more than a decade I've been
warning about the damage that this has
been doing to America and Senator Tom
cotton he is rightly outraged
it's a scandal me that we have trained
so many of the Chinese Communist Party's
brightest minds to go back to China to
compete for our jobs to take our
business and ultimately to steal our
property now what's most insane about
this is how the media have lapped up
China's propaganda now Politico has
praised China's handling of the pandemic
that it caused the New York Times is
worried it's worried about how Koba 19
could hurt China and CNN well it should
be just rebranded PR CN n PR CNN given
its shameless promotion of Chinese
propaganda even when the CCP kicks out
prominent journalists from our top
newspapers even when the CCP imprisons a
million ethnic Muslims even when as we
saw this past month China rips crosses
off churches and other buildings this is
a sick and twisted system
it's the Soviet Union on steroids we
didn't do almost anything significant
visa vie trade with the Soviet Union
remember we allowed no student student
transfers from the Soviet Union no
Soviet students at our top universities
and that worked out well for us in the
end
why because Reagan understood we weren't
going to enrich the USSR that would have
been disastrous for us we beat them it
was peace through strength and Trump had
taken important steps toward rebalancing
our relationship with China and then the
coronavirus hits
courtesy of China now obviously China is
hoping at this point for a Democrat in
the Oval Office that's beyond obvious
and of course we know what a Biden
presidency would be to the PRC a gift
let me be clear I believed in 1979 and
said so and I believe now that a rising
China is a positive development not only
for the people of China but for the
United States and the world
whole as we get closer to Election Day
remember this as many elites in academia
business and the media are doing China's
bidding you have a president who's
always seen them for what they really
are a communist power that is working
24/7 to eclipse us militarily and
economically if you think freedom will
march through Beijing anytime soon just
remember gentlemen square remember last
year's Hong Kong protests and remember
China's refusal to reveal all that it
knows about the virus that has now
killed more than 70,000 Americans and
those are my thoughts at the end of day
50 America and shutdown